Harold Reynolds Major League Baseball
Network analyst part of MLB's extensive
trade deadline coverage today a special
MLB tonight edition beginning at 1:00
Eastern and Harold Reynolds back on the
program HR how are you
VP you know on trade deadline we break
news so I wouldn't be a real journalist
if I didn't say what are you gonna do
with Jeopardy you take the job it's a
good question Harold and I'll provide an
answer for you when you're done with
this interview I'm doing well we get to
these trade deadlines we talk a big deal
and then rarely do we have big deals now
you have Bryce Harper who at least is
there for the taking I don't know what
it's going to take but what's the
likelihood that he's moved by the
Nationals today it's pretty high we just
stepped out of our production meeting
and it seems to me most of our insiders
and our former GM Dan O'Dowd really feel
like it's going to happen they think
it's going to happen I look at it this
way from my perspective I don't see him
the National Signing him back I don't
know if they're gonna catch the Phillies
or the Braves this year I'm making the
trade I got to get something back for
Bryce Harper I think you could do pretty
good with this and you got a number of
teams that are calling and inquiring so
I think it might happen okay what's it
gonna take to get Harper and who has
that to give up well you're gonna take
obviously somebody's gonna want some
young controllable prospects that's what
everybody looks for I look at the lineup
I think if you put him in Colorado and
you gave up a couple pictures from
Colorado and you put Bryce Harper in
that lineup he doesn't really have a
lineup around him I was saying in our
meeting this morning I think he can go
off like a JD Martinez did last year and
propel a lineup but we had a list of
teams I'm doing something on it now but
we were talking about the Dodgers the
Indians was real strong possibility him
going to Cleveland been in that lineup
and here was the big thing about
Cleveland is their plan for the World
Series now that's it
this window is going to close pretty
soon on them and so you take that run
right
now they've got everything they need
except that bat in the middle and Harper
could be that that that guy that really
takes that lineup to another level
because they're gonna win their division
they're not worried about that their
plan for World Series what happened in
Washington why where did the Nats go
wrong you know what I would love to seen
dusty come back I think they've been so
close you know Bryce Harper looking at
his career he's played for five managers
in eight years that's tough to get the
cohesive unit going and I felt like with
dusty they were there at that point
where they turned the corner players are
starting to buy into what he was doing
and they might have continued on they
love Dave Martinez they do they just
have a tough year again it's been the
health issues that always hit the
pitching staff or whatever but it just
hasn't flowed but I think dusty had them
going in the right direction yeah I also
I I don't know if the Nationals have
done this or can do it or will do this
where you just say to Bryce look we have
two teams we have some good offers for
you they're gonna give us prospects we
want to build around you but if you
don't want to be just say the word and
we will not make this deal you know
we'll have an agreement that we're gonna
continue to build around you have they
done it will they do with it can they do
that
well I think they're not it's not gonna
happen because Bryce is gonna test the
free agent market and I think any team
that gets him right now knows he's gonna
test the free agent market I think the
difference with Harper and Machado I
really think the Dodgers feel like they
got a chance to be one of the teams that
locks Machado up yeah so by getting him
in the fold letting him see the team how
it's ran everything they feel like they
can do a long-term deal with him
whoever gets Bryce right now I don't
think that's the feeling and I think
with the Nationals I think they're
realizing their window may not be there
to lock him up right now either
without him at least testing the market
to see where it's going to push the
money what kind of money are we talking
about for Bryce Harper you know it's
crazy
last year we
talking about 450 million dollars yeah
you know that's that's that was the
market remembers I don't know if the
batting averages hurt him
it's what everybody else looks at
differently now it's hard to understand
what people look at some people look at
well you hit 35 balls hard off is bad so
that you know that counts and you know
that's what they're looking at it yeah
exit velocity and home run derby hit 15
home runs over 450 feet you know some
people look at that other people looking
at the bat and a verse and might a
costume I still think he's got probably
the biggest appeal and mark ability of
any player there's just a magnet thing
to him that gravitates fans to him
whether you love him or you hate him and
that's that's that's good TV and that's
a good draw so he's gonna get paid for
that I think in itself and he's 26 years
old so I think he's gonna get that the
only the only twist I think might happen
is you may see he might be the first
forty million dollars a year yeah
somebody might say hey we'll give you 40
million for five years you don't you
don't know so it'll be interesting to
see exactly what the number ends up but
I think we're gonna be somewhere from
three to four hundred fifty million
talking to Harold Reynolds Major League
Baseball Network analyst yeah I had said
two years ago he's probably gonna be a
four hundred million dollar player if
you get somebody to give him a 10-year
deal that's gonna average 40 million I
said that I would give him five years at
forty million dollars if depending on
what city I'm in oh and that you know am
I ready to win I don't know if Colorado
can afford that I don't know if they
want to pay somebody that kind of money
I don't know if fans will come out to
you know to see you know you get the
return on your investment how would you
if you were looking at from Colorado's
perspective how could they get that
money back on their investment Colorado
well because he's gonna hit 80 home runs
a year in that ballpark I think that's
what they'd have to sell it to the the
challenge I think for the Rockies
and for any team for that matter his
Bryce is gonna want to win and he's
gonna have that opportunity I think to
pick the club to go to he may take less
money to being an organization that he
knows the future we're going to win he's
at that point now in his career and
money is going to be so great that he's
he's taking care of his kids kids kids
already so I think winnings gonna be the
big thing and the challenge for Colorado
for me is pitching how are you gonna
pitch and be competitive in that ball
park year and year out I also thought
you know a sidebar with this the trade
deadline Roberto Osuna who was traded to
the Astros but he's he's suspended right
now correct absolutely okay how are you
how can you trade somebody who's been
suspended boy Dan you must have been
listening to me talk in our meeting
alright I thought that was the one thing
I didn't didn't like about the deal
either I just felt like the Blue Jays
should not be able to benefit with the
player who's suspended you know they get
back a player who can pitch tonight in
Giles if they want and whatever else
they got so I think that's uh it reminds
me of a few years ago when somebody
would get suspended for peds and be
eligible for the postseason
yeah and the Commissioner made the
adjustment and no longer were you
allowed to play I think we'll see an
adjustment on this rule as well the
challenge will be how do they come about
it and what will it be we're gonna
discuss this on on the show because we
had a split camp across the board in our
meeting with Dan Odell Tom Verducci
myself Greg am singer everybody had
different opinions so we're gonna dive
into it but I'm in your camp I was
sitting there going how does that work I
don't think it's right and it sounds
like you're saying that well you can't
trade a player who's injured it's like
if the Lakers were thinking of trading
Alonso ball to San Antonio as part of
you know the Kawhi Leonard deal then he
quickly announced that he needed a knee
surgery that the Lakers couldn't trade
him so I don't know what the difference
is if somebody who's injured in
somebody's who suspended feels like if
you're injured and you want to trade for
somebody that's it I do Kay with that as
a
- somebody suspended for domestic
violence and you could still get rid of
them yeah I think this is one that
that's going to get worked out in the
end I still think we're in the beginning
stages of figuring all this out and you
know it's a new policy and I think
they've got the right policy in place
and I think they'll make the adjustment
I'm that's really the only answer I got
I can't think of anything else because
we haven't come across this you know
this is the first case first case of it
and the Astor's say they have a
zero-tolerance policy but they bring
this guy in and you've already won a
World Series so that there's not
pressure on you to like the Cubs brought
in Chapman and he had domestic violence
they had never won so they took a chance
and yeah I don't think any Cub fan is
you know gonna say yeah we won but you
know we had this guy who was accused of
domestic violence or whatever you know
with Chapman why bring in Osuna I don't
I don't care how good like there's
nobody else out there that you could
have said hey can we get somebody not
accused of domestic violence here maybe
he's not as good a pitcher as Osuna but
no kind of strange I didn't understand
that from the Astros perspective well
yeah they should have came out and just
said you know my job is to win games
he's 23 years old we like his stuff we
feel like in our conversations with him
that this is a guy that we can help in
this Clubhouse and fit and it's a
different perspective that way but I
honestly believe that if he's ineligible
for the postseason
the Astros don't make this deal because
they don't benefit yeah why would you do
it so they've got a guy now that they
know can be the last out in the ninth
inning of the World Series they can get
it from this guy and so again it brings
us back full circle what I said this is
a testing case that I think will be
discussed and and because of this things
are going to get changed a lot I think
all right before I let you go if Bryce
Harper is not traded today it's because
why the Nationals just didn't have the
nerve to do it man it's tough to trade a
franchise player for Rizzo to have to
deal this guy today
it's killing him to have to be in this
conversation and I don't know if the as
an organization they want the blowback
that's going to come their way
and that would be the reason that they
don't do this deal
HR good to talk to you tell the boys we
settle oh the trade deadline coverage
today and a special MLB tonight edition
beginning at 1:00 o'clock Eastern good
luck today thanks HR all right buddy
thank you look forward to seeing we got
a grab lunch
I'd love to thank you Harold Reynolds we
can talk a Ron and JLo since it HR is in
the inner circle with with a-rod and JLo
and it always drives Harold crazy when I
bring up a rotten JLo
are they getting married are you going
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]